what's going on guys this is rather I
hope I'm looking at the right place I
can't tell because there's light coming
down from in front of the camera and the
front of the cameras black so I can't
tell hopefully I'm looking at the right
spot hopefully I'm not like hey guys
what's going on this is rob you know I
think it'd be it'd be kind of weird but
maybe I'm looking in the right spot huh
okay there we go cool I'm looking in the
right spot I'm such a noob when it comes
to this it's absolutely pitiful anyway
this vlog is to let you guys know
there's a there's a bunch of stuff like
right now I'm working on hiring writers
for comics explain to make life a little
bit easier so I can you guys may have
noticed recently the videos just kind of
been coming out whenever and they're
about whatever and I like to have a
schedule so people know what to expect
every week so people who only want
Marvel stuff will come back like on
certain days of the week and I want to
get that schedule organized for you guys
so I'm looking at hiring writers just to
make life easier for me so I'm not
killing myself trying to reduce content
for you guys but a man things are
awesome i am going to be at the valiant
summit tomorrow because tomorrow is
Tuesday and it's 1150 right now and I
need to get in the process of like
getting ready to leave but I'm gonna be
the value of some of tomorrow um make
sure you guys follow valiant
entertainment on on Twitter on periscope
all that kind of good stuff and you'll
get all the info like when they're gonna
live seem like what time I gotta live
streaming all that kind of get stuff and
be able to keep up but um valiums like
one of the big indie creators that I'm
really digging you guys we have noticed
that myself and Vinny are doing a lot of
Valium stuff recently and I've really
been doing what they've been what
they've been putting out like bloodshot
and faith and so on and so forth I know
there's some big debate on faith but i
think that the content they're making is
pretty solid and and yeah so make sure
you all check that out speaking of which
also we're going to be doing a DC
rebirth for those of you guys who work
here so I'm on the fence on what I want
to do right now I want to cover new 52
stuff but i feel like if i did a video
on new 52 green arrow nobody would watch
it it would just not be a popular video
um this it's kind of weird have a weird
thing but DC we birth is really popular
so um I might just wait until DC rebirth
because it launches in like
10 days well really like nine days now
it starts in nine days and so what I'm
thinking about doing is covering VC
rebirth and then just getting like
actually just going through and doing
the character explanations Green Lantern
DC rebirth Wonder Woman so on and so
forth when DC we were actually launches
I don't know let me know what you guys
think down in the comments um also like
road to civil war I'm really hyped up
for I'm I wasn't going to i was going to
do a video about the ultimates but in
June there's a really important issue
issue number eight is coming out it's
going to be a pretty significant issue
for the ultimate from what I understand
and so I'm going to postpone the video
till then because then everything will
make sense but there's a really cool
stuff happening in there if you guys
aren't reading al Ewings Ultimates you
guys to do too but yeah so um with that
being said we're gonna grab Oh Rob plays
laughs I forgot about this rob plays so
I started a channel where I played video
games and so loud it's like commentary
right it's like talk to you guys about
stuff like social anxiety probably gonna
do one on how to talk to girls like how
to cope with depression because the
pressure was a part of my life at one
point um I am I going to do some
playthroughs i'm going to start
something called FPS fridays where I
literally just showcase games running in
4k because my computer is a 4k system so
i can play games in 4k and i'm thinking
about doing something like that we're
salute like every friday just a
different game what GTA 5 looks like in
4k in my system specs and all that kind
of stuff so you guys can get an idea of
what to expect if you choose to buy the
person I have and I don't know but it's
just kind of a channel for me to screw
around and just talk about stuff and
just get some up online and just kind of
whatever chit chat with you guys and so
that's not related to comic books so I
know some of you guys may be like if it
ain't comics I don't care and it's fun I
mean it's nothing wrong with that but
for those of you guys who are interested
in just talking about other things if
you suffer from social anxiety if you
don't know how to talk to the ladies you
know if you don't know why it is the
women love it loves a guy that knows how
to cook you know I talk to you about
stuff like that so anyway um yeah I'm
gonna go ahead and bounce off here and
I'll catch you guys later peace